welcome to horace hobbies the Jenna will
be discussed the latest tech news and
dove into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at why the new 9000
series from Intel he's just a desperate
attempt from them to stay relevant but
before we delve into that make sure hit
that subscribe button if you guys like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and pcs so as you
guys already know Intel is falling
behind a Verizon in terms of core County
and Rison is really starting to take a
good chunk of market share due to the
amazing value that provided to the
buyers to help combat against this it
was expected that Intel would be
launching an eight-core 16 third CPU
with the i7 9700 K but as we were
getting closer to the release date it
seems that in tow is just offering
another hex core processor with just a
core clock boost for the 9700 K and
instead they're going to be launching at
I $9.99 hundred K launch a mainstream
platform which will have eight cores and
16 threads
however the Intel I $9.99 hundred K is
most likely going to come in at a hefty
price like 500 or $550 and as a result
it is not really going to deter rising
buyers from buying the rise in 720 700 X
and buying this new I $9.99 hundred K
instead and asked for the rest of the
chips in the lineup they will most
likely just be coffee like chips with
just a little core clock increase and
once again they're going to be on the 14
nanometer process
well what about Z 390 is that going to
have something super special over the Z
370 chipset well unfortunately no and
the only thing the Z 390 platform is
going to have over the Z 370 platform is
support for USB 3.1 gen2 and the thing
is the support isn't even through the
chipset on board it's actually through a
third-party controller so pretty much
the whole new series coming out this
year is just Z 370 with a couple of
improvements and coffee like with some
minor clock speed boosts just like what
they have been doing for the last
several years so why is Intel doing this
and not
more competitive with the risin well the
thing is their ten nanometer process
development isn't going very well and it
is already delayed 229 teen and as a
result they need a filler series for
2018 and that is what this is because of
this they're essentially relaunching
populate just to stay relevant
while they actually work on the 10
nanometer process and get that ready for
launch and while they are added they can
make themselves appear more
consumer-friendly by offering backwards
compatibility for their new 9000 series
chips but the problem is is that the
9000 series chips aren't really new and
they're really just Bend 8000 series
chips and as a result it's not really
backwards compatible because it's a same
chips in essence so overall intelligence
bringing out another stale release by
adding a couple of gigahertz and calling
it at that and as a result rice is a
much better buy because not only does it
cost less and have more course it also
comes with a great stock cooler
thus I don't really believe that the
9000 series really fulfilled its purpose
which is fighting aim deep core 4 core
at a good price because the I 999
hundred K is way too expensive for most
people and so it's not really comparable
with the risin 720 700 X so should you
buy these new CPUs well if your main
focus is gaming and you like Intel then
of course these chips are gonna be great
it is just that Intel is not altering
anything new and they're being stale
once again even though there's a fierce
competition the 9700 K will most likely
be the best gaming CPU available even
better than the night 900 K because the
97 RK will most likely have higher clock
speed to the 99 hundred K and most games
can't even take advantage of 8 cores in
the first place thus if you really like
the performance that Intel is offering
and you're willing to pay the extra
price then yes there's nothing wrong
with going with Intel but I do recommend
that you check out and consider rising
before doing so so overall Intel is
having some trouble with the tendon
Dimitar process and so they're pretty
much just relaunching coffee like with
some minor clock speed improvements
and some minor upgrades on the
motherboard as well these CPUs will
indeed be good and provide great
performance but once again they have the
same issue as her predecessor which is
that they are still really overpriced
and don't deliver nearly as much value
as Rison it was anticipated that Intel
would change that
what's an octa core i7 processor this
year however unfortunately that doesn't
seem to be happening an Intel it just
seems to be launching the new 9000
series for the sake of launching a new
series every single year and staying
relevant so really it is quite a big
letdown from Intel but that's just what
I think
what do you guys think are you guys
going to buy the new Intel I $9.99
hundred K because it really is a good
chip albeit a bit expensive also what do
you guys think about Intel being on the
40 nanometer process once again make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
that I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to see
more videos just like this one but till
next time bye